Yellowstone's a big show yeah what do
you think of that Yellowstone I mean
they've been great to me they put
several of my songs on the show which
really just introduced me to
a crowd of people who might not listen
to radio or strain music I mean I have
people still you know come to the shows
and they're like before your acting gig
like I found your music through
Yellowstone so it's crazy to think that
a Show's soundtrack is really like that
helpful but for Yellowstone it is it
truly is and
Tyler Sheridan
um the writer and producer he's just
been good to me I mean he called me last
February and he's like
he said I got this idea he said I want
to create a character specifically for
you and he said wear your bell bottoms
sing your songs pretty much be you but
um go buy a musician named Abby
and I mean this is my first acting gig
I'm back in the fool my whole life but
this was like you know the real thing
and this was like a a huge thing
concerning it was my first too
um but I had so much fun I didn't know
what to expect I will say there are a
lot of similarities like with what I
normally do on a on a daily basis and
that I mean like it's a lot of hurry up
and wait you get ready for the scene you
you're waiting for your you know your
moment to shine and you've got like a
few minutes to show them what you can do
you know or even when it comes to like
learning the lines it's like learning a
song that I didn't write
um but everybody made me feel so
comfortable I mean I became great
friends with a lot of them Beth I mean
she is Kelly Riley she is so badass and
she's actually really kind uh when when
we first met because my very first scene
was with her
bring her up there buddy Kelly Riley
bring her up on there Kelly Riley you
know she's British oh yeah I know about
him yep she British so you should have
heard mine in her conversation we needed
a dank translator
yeah
but she's great she's still you can tell
that she's still got that Spitfire
Spirit about her
um but she is a a good human I mean she
made me buy assaults and oh dang I was
like okay I thought you gonna put me in
a headlock you making me bath salts bath
salts are
people die from them though
yeah well we're gonna do the right thing
with the bath salts
get rid of me
got it I'm gonna call her yeah man
that's swimmer's myth
tell me your first scene when you got to
get out there and do it because that's
when it's scary when they're like at
when the when you know when they say
action and it's on like you got to get
that line out and your brain is like
listening to you say it yeah it's like
you get stuck in that space kind of I
mean what was any of that like was it
I'll tell you I was I was real nervous
um that day but
I have I had a lot of family members
praying for me that day for me to not be
nervous and for me to just kind of be in
my body and people were sending me Good
Vibes and
um I really think that helped because
when I got out there to do it for some
crazy reason I was not nervous at all it
was like I had been doing it my whole
life
and I'm like
kind of freaked out that I wasn't
nervous you know wow I was nervous for
the kissing scene my first kissing scene
oh y'all were kissing on there dude
yes I said I'm gonna be on the name
church prayer list back at home
I didn't know what to expect with all
that either I'm like and who was the man
um he goes by Ryan on the show his name
is Ian Bowen he's become a dear friend
of mine too he's actually one of my
biggest Champions I mean he just he
shows up to shows he knows all the words
to my songs better than I do well heck
you kissed him I'd freaking polyfolio
yeah yeah he's following me
um bring up that man if we can huh
and Bowen Ian Bowen and he's out there
lip locking out there that's right and
it wasn't his first rodeo dang he's
handsome huh I mean he's all right I
mean all the Cowboys on that show they
yeah it's a real it's a real a lot of
handsomers on there huh a lot of
handsomers because I've seen the other
one I haven't seen this show yep
I know the some of the chaos but I've
not seen this show but yeah it looks
like a handsome guy
oh look at that huh oh yeah I mean we
got down to it that was the first our
first little interaction and
so did you guys talk before it yeah huh
yeah we did we uh we actually had a a
few days of working together before we
actually had to you know
do the do the thing
um but
yeah we just got to know each other and
I mean I did like I said I didn't know I
didn't know if like we really needed to
go in or like go in or whatever I mean
y'all made on there too or is just
kissing it's just kissing
I mean I wake up in a tent in one scene
um so it's kind of up to your
imagination oh damn but you know that's
that's as as risky as it got well my
imagination uh it has yeah yeah it's
it is not allowed around me anymore
uh-huh
put that thing away oh yeah yeah better
take the batteries out of that thing
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one